un truc c'est très beau concert
accueille à la chasse à savoir vous avez
vraiment dernièrement des gauches au
louvre c'est très bizarre
c'est un petit côté footballeurs des
années 80 j'adore parce que ça me fait
penser à celui là encore d'arbitrer ces
débats quand franck gastambide va
revenir entre cauet la bête voit
peut-être va peut-être que ça c'est
l'avenir
cette double vie avant la solidité même
pas écouté tous les chauves sur les mecs
qui sauve le monde et une diesel dwayne
johnson ya que le rebelle
michel blanc lorenzo lamas saint michel
blanc allaient boucherit alors fait son
retour à mme deslauriers franck
gastambide qui aurait préféré rater son
avion pour la terre inconnue jean michel
lemaire qui essayent de gagner sa place
pour la saison prochaine au tmp et
surtout vous allez découvrir un nouveau
cyril hanouna le cyril hanouna
sex-symbol êtes devenu un sex symbol
vous assure tout de suite si on va
démarrer par sa wii ah non non on va
démarrer par franck gastambide poste
vous voulez que ça se compterait pas
dire ça c'est cool parce que si vous
dites du mal de lui vous pétez est bon
rangasamy l'état
c
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe a perdu 6 millions de
téléspectateurs revenir sur son aventure
rendez vous en terre inconnue et le
regard des meufs quand ils rentrent en
plateau c'est ça
mais d'après vaut aussi pour regarder
jouer dans mes goûts sorti leur
entendement pas mon bébé chéri nous
raconter merci d'être là avec mon lozère
riffs de rendez vous en terre inconnue
alors vous avez remarqué des choses sur
cette image j'ai adoré parce que hier
soir sur france 2 il y avait le retour
de son doute cette émission
exceptionnelle vrai rendez vous en terre
inconnue ce programme où on emmène une
star dans une tribu du bout du monde
pour lui montrer que vivre sans télé
sans internet et son chien au débat eh
ben c'est pourri alors on sait tous que
si les stars fleurs la basse juste parce
qu'à pas de wifi et le pr le pauvre
franck a appris juste avant de partir à
la rencontre des derniers vendent du
jard dans le nord de l'inde que frédéric
lopez ne viendrait pas avec lui alors
que je remets à franck gastambide le
laurier riga qui passe le plus vite au
monde de l'ambiance d'arca à l'ambiance
rats sera alors qu'en font qu'au trophée
d'eric à l'aéroport on dirait deux potes
hyper content de partir en vacances
c'est magnifique on y va pour dix
minutes après l'ambiance va un peu
changer
je ne pars pantin je suis choqué par la
nouvelle
c'est l'appel dû à des colonies mon gars
c'est pas possible ça fait la paix il
est sérieux ce qu'on en fait et en
exclusivité voilà ce que pense et à ce
moment là
franck gastambide jeudi matin la vie de
ma mère je t'ai tueur c'est vrai franck
ou pas non mais là j'étais beaucoup plus
bon à rien honnêtement il ya plus de son
plus d'image soit vraiment tu t'y
attendais pas du temps pas du tout pas
du tout mais en plus la ctu vienne qui
tu étais proche c'est déjà un peu
fragile
ouais tu dis rien comme que je connaisse
pas avec lui il me dit non je pars pas
t'es perdu complètement tu vois vraiment
pour noël je voulais dire un truc qui
m'a beaucoup touché c'est que tu as été
tu m'a appelé avant de partir de
l'aéroport et je te jure que ça va ça
m'a aussi est touchée de ouf
tu vois que tu m'a appelé et que vous
cessez la dernière box a entendu avant
de partir alors que tu étais très
enfants mais tout est niché le match
race track et ça me fait plaisir
personne d'autres répondent des
personnes condamnées mais non seulement
non seulement tu sais que tu compte
beaucoup pour moi mais en plus
j'appelais mon pote qui est un
professionnel de la télé et tu vois
c'est ça qui comptait aussi il m'a dit
voilà il n'est pas là tout ça j barocci
3 est pas mon numéro
[Rires]
alors vous êtes donc partis à 7000 km de
paris avec un gars que vous ne
connaissiez pas alors faire un blabla
car pendant deux heures avec un inconnu
s'est déjà horrible alors quinze jours
de blabla car avec un inconnu
j'en parle même pas je vous comprends
vous avez beaucoup qui fait en inde vous
avez beaucoup qu'il fait mais j'avais
aussi beaucoup pas qui je fais je vous
remets le laurier du gars qui part au
bout du monde mais qui en fait est au
bout de sa vie cardiaque femme n'était
pas comme un ouf à l'idée de partir sans
faute de riscle opel vont avoir qu'avec
le nouveau ce n'est pas la franche
camaraderie quoique je vous emmène dans
une région considérée par ses habitants
comme la terre d'études
[Rires]
dentifrice qui vont super chien pendant
ces quinze jours j'ai les banques déjà
vous êtes régalés et demain se lève à 3h
[Musique]
et les beauvaisiens brisé en au célèbre
héros de cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant de belles choses de beaux
moments et de d'émotion résumer comme ça
depuis comme ça à néant dans tout alors
on va rentrer tous les moments d'émotion
aussi avec ses formes il a fait très
belle émission hier et ont une autre
image de fond il est temps de remettre
des lots ria touche pas à mon poste
évidemment jean michel maire sait faire
deux choses dans la vie bafouillé et
fayoter alors qu'on savait qu'il pouvait
pas aligner trois mots sans bafouiller
maintenant on sait qu'ils ne peut pas le
nier trois mots sans faille au thé
auprès de vous cyril s'est alors comme
la fin de saison approche et qui vont
encore être là l'année prochaine il a
trouvé cette solution pour pour vous
convaincre de sa présence est pas sûr ça
fonctionne parce que je remets à jean
michel maire le laurier du fawe fayot
[Musique]
c'est une info je donne c'est un fait
c'est que vous êtes le génie le mozart
du paf ça c'est pas moi qui lis les
audiences fait ça vient du grec
kernews qui veut dire seigneur maître
des célébrations votre temps il gagne
tout le temps pour que ton ils gagnent
enfin mieux si vous avez déjà monter
encore un peu plus haut la barre on est
en terme d'animation je pousse et c'est
ouf personne ne fait ça au niveau
léchage de boue on est pas mal là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'êtes l'amitié d'en dégoûter
pas des soins alors il faut vous
demander je vais maintenant évoquer les
nouvelles chroniqueuses qui aurait pu
gagner la star academy 6 tous les autres
candidats avait été enlevé par des
extraterrestres en kiosque antonetti
elle est persuadée qu'elle chante
hyper-v ramener tout le monde voit que
c'est pas vrai francesca parle beaucoup
et comme elle veut être sûre d'être
prête à parler tout de suite à ne ferme
jamais la bouche elle joue comme ça
alors vous allez voir il ya aussi autre
chose que j'ai remarquée francesca temps
de vous faire rire
non ça marche pas trop et je remets à
notre ami france jusqu'à l'orée de la
meuf qui est bien meilleur chroniqueuse
que chanteuse
en même temps c'était pas trop difficile
concentrez-vous sur la bouche de
francesca c'est incroyable dit la vérité
j'espère vous êtes thon rouge vous êtes
et 8 où va l'argent n'a pas d'odeur
c'est juste une photo je sais qu'ils
pensaient avoir trouvé une façon de
lancer des vidéos qu'allez vous fait
rire mais siri je crois que c'est raté
avec votre tête de série car marseille
j'adore mars et alors on va un peu lié
l'espagne je suivais notariat tombe bien
vous aux états unis des maîtresses ça
tombe bien pour vol à cette année des
questions pourquoi il n'est pas parti
avec frédéric lopez dans mon ami ramdjee
voilà qui vient d'envoyer ça donc je
vous le dis vous dira tout dans un sens
qu'on va revenir sur rendez vous au
terrain côté alors pour finir parmi les
animateurs les plus sexy de france et
laurent delahousse
il ya nelson monfort et maintenant il ya
donc cyril hanouna plus connu sous le
nom de l'animal bien sûr ans avant vous
faisait rire tout le monde maintenant
vous fait fantasmer tout le monde
surtout quand vous tenez dans vos mains
une longue règle en guise de cravate les
téléspectatrices qui m'écrivent tous les
jours qu'on dira congénères de façon
quotidienne à côté dans sex symbol
commun je vous remets le laurier du seul
animateur qui pourrait jouer dans 50
nuance de merguez
qu'est ce
[Musique]
m
au pénis mêmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]